では よろしくお願いします
えっと まあ今日のテーマは
まあ一応何でしたっけ？で
あの まああの まあ 2行目に書いてるところだけなんですけど
理解してほしいのは この人間はこの壊れてしまって破壊して堕落するのは
この心の中から現れる原因なんです
自分の中から 外から攻撃されるわけじゃないんです
で 外から攻撃されて 人が不幸になって堕落して潰れたっていうことではなくて
内から現れてくる火に火で
まあ焼か焼かれてしまいます
まあそういうことで で
まあそういうことで まあこれは皆様に報告されている日本のタイトルです
で 私は喋るのは前のタイトルで喋ります
ちょっと違ってるかもしれません
で では早速あの話始まります
で この こういうタイトルをなぜ作ったかという
元になっている経典がございまして
まあまず楽しくその経典を読んでみましょうと
このカリンガルスッタンというサンユッタニカーヤに入っている経典で
これどうやって読むんですかね
丸太の丸木の枕  丸木の枕という
まあカリンガラといえば丸木という意味ですが
枕っていうのが入ってないんですけど
一応日本訳するときはそういう風にしなくちゃいけないんです
では この経典はどういう経典でしょうかと
カリンガルーパダハナンダハナビッカウェータラヒリッチョビビハランティアッパマッターアターピノウパサナスミン
テサンラージャ ちょっと間違ってます
ラージャマガドアジャータサットゥヴェーデーヒプットーナラパティオータランナラパティアランマナンという風に
まあこの一応経典の内容はそういう風に始まります
で まあ一応あの簡単な
ちょっといい加減な訳かもしれませんだけど
パーリ語の専門の方々はいろいろ文句を言うかもしれませんけど
比丘たちよ 現在というのは今のところでという意味なんですね
現在 リッチャビ族は丸木を枕にして怠ることなく
これは読めない 読みえ？きゅう？弓術に励みながら生活している
マガダ国王ヴェーデーヒプッタアジャータサットゥは攻撃するための隙間を見つからない
というところでわかりやすいんです
ちょっと歴史的な背景を言うと
この おそらくこのマケド国王っていうのは
お釈迦様の大変な友人の方で
息子が父親を殺しちゃったんですね
このアジャースアジャータサットゥという
で で それから自分が王になってしまったんです
では あまりにも若いんですよ
だから自分が自分の領土を大きくしようと
よく戦争しているんです
他の国々と で 一番大きい国っていうのはコーサラ国でしたけど
このコーサラ国には結構攻撃するんです
コーサラ国にいたコーサラ王様は
自分の父親とだいたい同じ年
で これはもう息子の時代だからね
まあ若いんですよ それなのに若いんだから
大体若者は集まりますから
軍隊をまあそろってコーサラ国を攻撃する
コーサラ国は大きいし
かなり政治的にしっかりしているし
もうすぐ潰しちゃうんですね
アジャータサットゥの軍隊を
それでまた逃げる 逃げてまたもうゆっくりとまた軍隊を集めて
また行って攻撃する これもいつでもまたコーサラ王がもうみんな追い出すんです
追い出されたところで
これでもう諦めません
また一人に達すると また行ってコーサラ国を攻撃する
コーサラ王様も一応親切にしていたんですよ
もうこの子はもう何やってるのかっていうことで
また攻撃してきたところで言って
徹底的に攻撃して アジャースアジャータサットゥヴェーデーヒプッタですね
この名前です フルネームは
昔パーリ語ではこのファミリーネームというか
このそれがこの母親の名前を使うんです
父親の名前ではなくて
だからウェーデーヒプッタっていうのは
ウェーデーヒという女性の息子っていうことなんです
それ母親の名前ですね
ローマ字で見てください
こちらで それでこのアジャータサットを捕まったんです
捕まって このものすごく侮辱しちゃったんです
あの 何て言いますか このまあ戦争で捕まった人だから
でも隣の国の王様なんですけど
全部足やら手やら全部もう捕ま縛っておいて
大変な侮辱して そうやって命令したんです
ああいうできるだけあいつをね
侮辱して プライド粉々残して私のところに連れてこいと
そこでもうこの若い王様を捕まって
そうやってもう全部王としてのあれは全部脱がせちゃって
ただの捕虜として捕まって
コーサラ王様の前に捨てちゃったんです
もう何の立場もない もう簡単に殺すべきですけどね
まあ隣の国から来た人だから
それでコーサラ王様も怒鳴ったんですね
お前はどんな調子でしょうかと
国王でしたでしょうと
今 ただの私のまあ何て言いますか
え？捕虜ではないかと
お前殺すなりに切るなりに何でも私にできますよと
どんな拷問もできますよと
で この若い王様は何も言わない
もうしょうがない もう終わったんだからね
それでまあお釈迦様 仏教のコーサラ王さんは仏教でしょうし
マケデ国王も自分の友人でしたし
お釈迦様の関係があるんだからね
で 何のことなく まあ自分の娘がいたんです
また娘に結婚させて連れてきなさいと
大事にしなさいと 私の娘だよと言って
また帰したんです そうすると戦争できないんです
戦うことは 王様は義理の父親になるんだから
だからちゃんと息子として
どうしても出来が悪いし
経験はないし だからこの子には誰かがどこかで父親が必要やとということも考えて
そうしてあげたんです
それも素晴らしい結論で
現代人とは違ってね もう誰も損することがなく
もう大変見事にいい解決法を出してあげるという
戦略することもされることも
そういう惨めになることも何もなく
でも行儀が悪い 性格が悪いんだったら
それなりのしつけはするということで
で それからコーサラ国をもう攻めることはできなくなっちゃったんです
でももう目減り それから何するかというと
リッチェリ国を攻撃しようとする
これリッチェリっていうのは共和国で
どちらかというと独裁制度ではなくて民主主義制度なんです
それでお釈迦様は政治的にはリッチェリ国はとても気に入りなんです
この王制よりは共和主義で
共和国としてみんなまとめて議会をやって国を政治する方が
お釈迦様はこの方がやっぱりどちらかというとその方が好みなんです
お釈迦様はサンガ集団も出家集団もやっぱり一つの組織だから政治的なんですね
その時もサンガの運営は全部民主主義にもう設定しているんです
それをお釈迦様が考えた政治的な理想的なモデルなんです
サンガは それで でお釈迦様はいろいろ工夫するんですよ
ウェーサーラ国が潰れないようにと
すごく工夫するんです
でもウェーサーラ国にいるリッチェリ族が民主主義だから
どこかで気楽なんですね
王様一人だったら気楽で政治できません
これ議会で決めるんだから
私が風邪引いたんだから今日は参加しませんよということもできるし
ちょっとどこかで遊びに行きますから
他の方々はやってくださいということもできるし
だから政治のことに対してはどこかで気楽というところがあるんで
それは悪くはないんですけど
お釈迦様から見れば 周りにいるのは全部独裁的な王政の国々なんですね
だからこれやばいと すぐ潰れますよと
ということでいろいろアドバイスをするんです
即ちその国に行く で よく心配する
政治的にはお釈迦様は心配する
だからお釈迦様があなた方は滅びないように
滅びないように こういうこういう戒め
こういうこういうことを気をつけなさいよと
七つの戒めまで教えてあげたんです
かなり心配なさっていたんです
だからまあ ある日 そういうウェーサーリの王家の人々が頑張っているのを見て教えたことなんですね
その若者たちがすごい厳しい訓練を受けているんです
王家の人々だから結構贅沢できますよ
でもみんなこの 何て言いますか
ただ丸太をね 枕にして寝て
ずっとこの休日をやっているんです
まあ訓練しているんです
だから見るからにすごく何の贅沢もなく
結構大変頑張っているんです
そういうこと はい 次 それでちょっとであのアジャサットが待ち構えているんですよ
コーサル国は攻めることもできないし
だったら別な国やってやるぞということで
自分の国を大きくしたいんだから待ち構えてはいるんですよ
待ち構えているんですけど
全然隙間がないんですね
並ぶと大多蘭 大多蘭っていうのは
この 例えば川の入るところとかね
沐浴するために船場とかね
そういう風に入るところっていう意味なんです
大多蘭だから入るところ
降りるところはないんです
このウェーサーリ国で
みんなずっともう訓練中で
もうなかなか大変なんです
その人々に攻撃かけちゃうと
もうどうなるかわからないということで
で ネラベティアーランマなんていうと
それであのバビサンティビッカーレアナガタマッダーナンリッチェリースクマーラ
ムドゥタルナハッタパーダームドゥカーすセイヤーストゥーランボーホーツーツールビンボー読めなくなっちゃった
トゥーラビンボーハナーストゥーラビンボーハナースヤーワスリヤスリヤスリユッカマナセイヤンカッペンテ
でまあ簡単な意味はこちらに書いてますから
比丘らよ 将来リッチェリーたちは虚弱になり
手足が柔らかくなり 綿を入れてふわふわになった寝具にもう太陽が昇るまで寝る時期が来ますと
で ちょっとパーリ語の言葉をちょっと見てもいいと思います
アナガタマッダーなんていうのは
これから将来のことを予言するんですね
大体 お釈迦様は予言したものっていうのはすべて見事に当たっているんです
で 予言して将来のことを言っている経典というのは
それなりにいくつかあります
はこうなるんだ こうなるんだ
こうなるんだと言ってることはもうほとんどもうそうなっているんです
一つのカラス で 将来リッチでスクマーラっていうのは
とても贅沢に楽をするんですよ
すごく柔らかいという意味なんです
スクマーラっていうのは
大体女性に使う言葉なんですけど
すごく美しいという意味もあります
で 贅沢するともう誰の体も結構柔らかくはなるんです
それなりに綺麗にもなります
ムドゥタルナハッタパーダ
ムドゥっていうのはすごくソフト
柔らかい タルナっていうのは
この またも同じ柔らかいという意味で
このよく使うのはこの葉っぱに使うんで
葉っぱが小さく出てくる時はすごく柔らかいんですね
そんな感じで ハッタパーダ手足なんかはそうやってこの柔らかい葉っぱのように
かなりきれいなのはきれいなんですけど
柔らかくなってしまうんだと
だから弓なんか刀なんか持てるわけじゃないんですよ
それだからもう硬いところで寝ることもできなくなるんです
だからもうかなりトゥーランでトゥーラビンボーハナース
まあ枕やらだけじゃなくて
あれなんて言いますか
マットレスまであって
それはちゃんと綿を入れてふわふわ状態にしてもう寝る
寝る時も太陽が昇るまで寝ると
そういう時期が来ますよと
はい テーサン ラージャマーガドアジャータサットーヴェーデーヒプットーラッチャティオータランラッチャティアラムナ
テーサン その彼らに対して
そのもう贅沢する坊ちゃまになったところで
国の政治家たちが 王子たちが
王子たちが坊ちゃまになったところで
マーガドアジャータサットーヴェーデーヒプットー
このアジャータサットウがもうチャンスですということで
ラッチャティオータランラッチャティっていうのはなる得るだろうという
ちょっと未来形なんですね
で 攻撃するための隙間を見出すのです
その時 アジャータサットウのもうやりたい放題だと
で こちらはウェーサーリの王子たちがもう結構坊ちゃんになっちゃって
かなり贅沢で よく食べて
もうもう太陽が出るまで寝て
まだ手足なんかすごく柔らかくなっちゃって
もう戦えるところじゃないんですね
それの隙間で まあそれがもうアジャータサットに対してはすごくいいチャンスだよと
じゃあまあ大体まあポイントはそこまでなんですけど
で みんなかなり苦労して頑張ってる時はもう攻撃はされない
敵はいません しかし 苦労しないで贅沢に陥って溺れてしまったところで
もう潰れますよと なんです
で それだいたら俗世間の話だから
お釈迦様にはそれは関係ないし
だから仏教にそのたとえを合わせているんです
お釈迦様は自分の弟子たちにそれを注意したいんです
だから弟子たちに言うんです
カリングーパダーナビッカウェーターイビクウイハランティアッパマッタアターピノパダーナスミン
エータラヒ 今頃 お釈迦様がいる時は
ビクビクたちがカリングーパダーナ
まあ丸太を枕にして生活して
それ一つの象徴なんですよ
何も贅沢しないということで
だからどこかで外で 寝る
寝る時は外で 夜も何かに丸か丸太でも何でもいいんだから
ちょっとちょっと横になるだけの生活をしているんですね
結構苦労しているんです
お坊さんたちはただ単にもう苦労しているわけではなくて
アッパマッタ怠ることなく
アーターピーの精進しています
パダーナスミン修行に
だからもう寝るとこはどうでもいい
もうもう体洗うことあってもなくても
食べるものあってもなくてもどうでもいいっていうことで
もう何の贅沢も贅沢も考えないで
体に甘えないで ものすごい必死で修行しているんだと
今頃は お釈迦様のとこはテーサンマーローパーピーマー
彼らに対しては マーローマーラが
いわゆる まあこれも象徴的な悪魔ということなんですけど
悪しきものには狙われていたら隙間は見つかりません
悪魔には降りるところ
入るところはありませんと
並べてアーランマナン
アーランマナンというのは何かいいわけ
対処ですね 何かこのお坊さんがこちらで引っかかっているんだというところで
マーラが攻撃するんだと
それはできないんだと
今頃の比丘たちの場合は
みんなもう丸太を枕にして寝る時はね
まあ結構頑張っているんだと
はい それで将来はバビサンティビッカウェーアナガタマッダーナンビクースクマームドゥタルナハッタバーダ
それで将来になってくると
比丘たちも結構スクーマ
もう体が柔らかくて贅沢しちゃって
ムドゥタルナハッタバーダ手足もすごく柔らかくても赤いというかね
まあもう労働していないんだから
そうやって贅沢的になって
体も柔らかくなってしまいますと
テームドゥカースセイアース
とてもとても柔らかい
ふわふわしている 寝具なんかでもう寝ているんだと
トゥートゥーランビトゥーラビンボーハナース
あのマットレスやらかけるものやら敷布団何から何までかなり贅沢なものを使うようになっているんだと
それでヤーワスリユッガマナ
太陽が昇るまでセイアンカッピッサンで寝ているんだと
比丘たちも将来は それでテーサンマーローパーピーマーラッチャディオーターラン
彼らに対してはもう悪しきものを
悪魔がもうチャンスだよと
もう攻撃することはできるんだと
ラッチャティアーランマナ
まあいいわけもありますと
攻撃する なんとかなんとかっていうことで
だからというふうに言い渡る
それでタスマーティヒャビッカウェ
だからビクたちよ 従ってビクラよ
エヴァンシッキタッバン
このように戒めなさいよと
このように戒めなさいよ
カリンガルーパダーナヴィーリッサマ
枕なんて言いますか 丸太を枕にして
修行に怠ることなく励もうということで戒めるべきであると
で あなた方もちゃんとこういうふうにやりましょうということで
頑張りましょうということで
それで一応経典は終わると思います
で これなんですね このポイントは
そちらで何言ってるかというと
人間は苦労して贅沢はあまり期待しないで
頑張っている場合はもう倒れることはないんですよ
潰れることはないんです
外からでも攻撃することはできないんです
そう まあヴィジランスと英語で言うんですけど
よく自分のことは心配して
しっかりと生きている時は問題はありません
それでどうなるかというと
苦労して生活すると じわじわと経済的にもうまくいくでしょうに
寝る時間少なくして すごい真剣に体を使って頑張っていると
もう当然ながら経済的な豊かさが出てくる
そうなるとどうなるんでしょうかね
家がもっと楽に作るわ
もっと高価なベッドを買うようになるわとかね
で 遊ぶいろんな道具を買ったりするわ
たとえテレビ買っても
まあもうお金あるところで余裕があるんだから
テレビ一台でも買ってやりましょうと思ったら
それで結構時間なくなるんですよ
で そういうふうなことでどんどん贅沢に生えると
人間の体がもう期待できなくなっちゃうんです
もう頑張れなくなっちゃうんで
例えば ただのもう平ら
もうどこでもいいんだから
床の上でもそのまま倒れて寝る人がもうすぐ起きられますよ
かなり高価なもう寝具の中で気分よく寝ちゃうと
もう起きられません それであれこれやと
家の中でいろんな道具が増えると結構時間かかりますよ
例えば まあ食べるものにも合わせて食器あるでしょうに
ほんのもう 1グラム  2 グラムぐらいのものを何か作って
それには別な皿 それでおしんこを入れる別な皿
それであれ 黄色いやつはなんでしたっけ？たくあんは別な
それに合わせた皿とか
味噌汁のまたそれなりの皿とか
まあいろいろまあくだらん食べ物のやり方
種類は作って作って もう一人が食べるところ
もう皿はだいたいまあ 10枚とかね
15枚とかね まあそれでも物足らないでしょうし
それも作ることでも考えてみれば
一つ一つ取り出して それにちゃんと食事を盛って
また食卓にそれは用意して
それで食べてからまた片付くとかね
どれほど時間かかるのかと
それだけどれほどああいうくだらんことに自分の精神力
体力 使うのかと かえって一体自分が 1 日中何やったんですかと
朝ごはん作って もう昼ご飯作り
それでもう晩御飯作ったらもうもう暇がないんだと
何する暇も本なんか新聞なんか読んだり
もうそんな暇がない 忙しいんだと平気で言うでしょうに
忙しいんだったら何やってるんでしょうかというと
あの皿をまた洗って また拭いて
また丁寧に片付けていかなくちゃいけないんだから
漆のものっていうのは
他の食器と一緒に洗えないし
いろいろ大変ですよ で
だからそういう贅沢になってくると
そういう 我々には この人間として習うべきものを知るべきものを体鍛えすることっていうのは全部なくなるんですね
それでどんどん堕落して
もう壊れてしまいます
だから まあ比丘たちに言っているのは
贅沢だけはするなよと
将来はあんた方はそうなるんだよと
それで あのリッチアイ国も将来は潰れますよと言っておいたんですけど
お釈迦様は ものの見事に潰れちゃったんです
その時はまあ お釈迦様はいたかいなかったかって
ちょっと定かではないんですけど
お釈迦様がいらっしゃった時
潰れたならば かなりお年になってからなんです
お釈迦様は自分には体力ある限りはリッチ国を攻められないように守ってあげていたんです
お釈迦様もまあまあ 歳ぐらいもうちょっとになると
もうほとんど俗世間のことにはあまり口は出さないし
まあ体も弱かったしね
病気とかいろいろありましたし
だからまあ あまり行くことはできなかったんですけど
一応最後の旅でも一回は行きましたし
ということは お釈迦様が亡くなってからでしょう
涅槃に入ってからですね
サーリが潰れたのは じゃあやっちゃったんです
とにかく だからお釈迦様は予言した通りに
ワッサカーラという大臣がいて
金する賢い人がね で 街を作って
大きな街を作ったんです
ウェーサーリの国のもう近いところで
そちらに首都を引っ越しさせたんです
させて いろいろワッジ族をね
中からお互いに仲が悪くなるように
いわゆる分立させるんですよ
お互いに分立しちゃうと
民主主義は成り立たないんです
互いに批判することになると
それでまあ贅沢にも陥っていたし
いとも簡単にもう跡形もなく潰してしまっちゃったんです
で 出家の場合でも同じことで
で 今になってくると お坊さん
昔 お釈迦様の時代では捨てた布切れ拾ってきて
あの縫い合わせて もうかなり見た目は良くなかったと思いますけど
そういうものを着ていたんですけど
今はまだまだテーラワーダの衣はそれほど高くはないんですけど
もう大乗の衣だったらまあ万
万 万というのはまあ何のこともない
これは普通の値段です
料亭でしかご飯食わないとかね
これがまあ北伝仏教だけではなくて
南伝仏教でもこれは結構見えます
贅沢する坊主たちはもう何もあてにならない
何かアドバイス受けたっても何もできません
贅沢して金があるんだから
何か何とか大臣にちょっと電話かけてくれませんかとか言ったら
それはできます 法律的にはそれだけでも不正行為でしょうに
そういう偉い金持ち 政治家とか仲良くすることだけ修行にして
まあまあいるんです 自分の国の場合
お坊さんってかなり政治には興味ありますからね
まあミャンマーでもなかなか
もう自分一人で贅沢することは目立っている
タイでもそうなんです
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃったことは
予言したことは外れているわけじゃないんです
インドでももう外れてしまったんです
部派仏教出てきて 大乗仏教なんか現れる時は
この大乗仏教というのは
思想として別にいろんな自由な思想
例えばテーラワーダ世界では大乗仏教は批判していますよ
大体どちらが批判するかというと
この生活がだらしなくなったこと
お釈迦様のこの道徳的な道から脱線したこと
考え方が違うところは
もうどんどん論争してね
その考え方 君 ちょっと違うんじゃないかなと
それはすごく優しく話し合いますけど
あの坊主として堕落すると
もう相手にもしない だから大乗仏教は一概に悪いということではなくて
大乗の仏教の中でもそれなりに優れた思考やらね
いろんなことは思想的に発展するところは
それはそれでいいんですけど
人間としてどうなのか
頭だけ出っ張りでもう訳の分からないことを喋ったっても
人間としてどうなのかというところはものすごく堕落しちゃうんですね
そこはすごく悩んでいる問題なんですね
仏教は うん はい 大体 それでタイトルはね
日本語のタイトル何でしたっけ？自分の身は安全ですかと
私はセキュリティオブライフというタイトルをつけましたから
安全ですかっていうね
自分の人生のセキュリティはありますかと
そこを気をつけなさいよということは
やっぱり贅沢に溺れると何がなくなるかというと
セキュリティがなくなっちゃうんです
だからいろいろ昔のね
いろんな物語なんかあるような感じで宝物を探しに行くでしょうしね
で 宝物を探しに行く場合は
ものすごい険しいところに行って
猛獣と戦って 化け物と戦って
命拾いして なんとか宝物をもらうというエピソード
話ね 物語あるでしょうに
だからそういう 贅沢欲しいというと
その道っていうのは命取りなんです
だから人間何を優先するのかっていうこと
安全な生き方を優先するのか
あるいはもう贅沢に溺れてすぐ自己破壊するのかっていうことは考えてほしいんです
そこら辺で それは今日のテーマはもうあまりにも簡単すぎて
私にはあまり面白くないんですけど
で 続けてやります 今日は長くないんです